las d'attendre les aides de l'état ils
sont venus chercher des réponses
concrètes à leurs demandes ces petits
planteurs du galion ont été reçus ici à
la sous préfecture pour les défendre lé
syndicat des planteurs et la sénatrice
catherine conconne aujourd'hui les
planteurs sont n'a pas d'argent pour
nourrir les familles n'ont pas d'argent
pour acheter du matériel pour faire leur
cote ils sont en interdit bancaire vaut
certains ils n'ont les chéquiers sont
puis les cartes bancaires bref y'a d'une
vraie misère d'une nouvelle difficulté
et ce n'est pas normal parce que la
tendance et 200 exploitations ses sens
et qu'un petit planteur ses 4000
hectares de terres qui aménage le
territoire ces huit cent mille visiteurs
dans les distilleries dalle usine
bref c'est un potentiel de développement
et pourtant on est en train de mendier
alors que les aides sont dues les petits
planteurs sont soumis à de nouvelles
procédures appelé m
à eux c'est des mesures agro
environnementales et climatiques
synonyme d agriculture propre mais aussi
de contraintes budgétaires
pour avoir une idée les montants au la
coupe envers ses 800 euros par état et
pour le désherbage chimique le remplace
un désherbage par une exploration c'est
à peu près 700 euros par état c'est sous
ces fours à confier des projets ou pas
plus s'organiser et lorsqu'on voit le
jour arriveront apparition sur le coin
alors là on entre deux se paniquer en sa
qualité de sénatrice catherine conconne
qui connaît bien le dossier compte
demander une aide exceptionnelle
je le ferai parce que les ouates typique
sur certains paiements ont engendré des
agios bancaires des mots
des indemnités de retard au niveau de la
sécurité sociale et ça c'est pas la
faute des planteurs qui peuvent pas être
victime du moteur des autres donc je
vais demander au ministère dès la
semaine prochaine une aide
exceptionnelle pour qu'on puisse leur
donner de quoi réparer certains les
dossiers des petits planteurs du galion
ont été traitées par les services de
l'état pour l'année 2016
ils seront payés le 29 mars prochain
2017 et 2018 restent en suspens sans
compter d'autres problèmes comme l'aide
à la balance source de tracas chaque
année